the prologue of the movie informs us
about the U.S Air Force dropping a
highly potent non-nuclear bomb in a
remote region of Afghanistan official
statements claim that the bomb was used
to destroy a key Insurgent stronghold in
the area however there were circulating
rumors regarding disturbing activities
in the hours prior to the bombing at
present we find a couple of fighter
pilots named captain Kate Sinclair and
Johnson from the Royal Air Force flying
over Afghanistan when they are suddenly
attacked by Afghani Insurgent troops as
their aircraft get hit both Pilots eject
themselves from their seats in Parachute
to the ground Kate loses Consciousness
upon impact during which she experiences
a vision of her mother and son shortly
after she is woken up by Johnson but
they are soon surrounded by a group of
armed insurgents sensing their arrival
Johnson instructs Kate to play dead
while he turns around to deal with them
unfortunately this turns out to be a bad
idea as he is immediately killed when
one of the insurgents approaches Kate
she takes out her gun and shoots him she
then uses his body as a shield to take
down the remaining threats after
successfully wiping out the enemies Kate
bids an emotional goodbye to her
teammate before venturing out on her way
she tries to establish contact with her
base but to no avail well meanwhile one
of the insurgents seems to have survived
the shootout so he immediately summons
for extra backup shortly after Kate
notices the insurgents approaching her
on their trucks prompting her to seek
refuge in a bunker area the Bunker's
door is marked with a warning sign in
Russian which she cannot comprehend the
entrance door is heavily locked and
before she can attempt to open it the
insurgents opened fire upon her Kate
quickly takes cover behind a metal
container and returns fire amidst the
intense shootout one of the insurgents
fires a rocket launcher that opens the
Bunker's door giving Kate the chance to
sneak inside the dark place she grabs
her glow stick and climbs down to the
basement to avoid her pursuers as she
Ventures deeper into the area she finds
additional Russian signs some beds and a
row of gas masks soon after she stumbles
Upon A decomposed body which appears to
be that of a scientist on a desk she
finds several Russian notes and a
portable hard drive which she opts to
take with her Upon A Brief investigation
she realizes that this is a testing lab
for human subjects evident from the
presence of multiple pods containing
bodies before long the insurgents also
make their way into the lab they are
equally disturbed by the contents within
Kate takes advantage of their
distraction and knocks out a man before
snatching his gun amidst the hail of
gunshots one of the pod's shatters
releasing a humanoid figure as Kate runs
out of ammo she enters a ventilation
docked in an attempt to escape soon
after the figure awakens revealing
itself is a long clawed flesh hungry
monster it instantly kills one of the
insurgents and feeds on his flesh
meanwhile an Insurgent manages to
apprehend Kate but she cleverly uses a
flare to subdue him she then climbs up
the basement but as soon as she gets on
the top one of the men grabs her leg
Kate tries to free herself by kicking
him but fails just then a monstrous
entity appears and kills the man with a
single lethal strike leaving Kate in a
State of Shock overwhelmed by fear she
races towards the exit door and narrowly
escapes the clutches of the creature but
sadly she gets injured in the process
following this Kate fires a few shots to
fend off the monster and locks the door
with chains she is then confronted by an
Insurgent named Kabir who is waiting for
his comrades however he hastily Retreats
upon spotting the creature despite her
pain Kate begins to walk through the
desert terrain and eventually reaches a
road sometime later she is found by a
team of American soldiers who were sent
to look for the missing Pilots they
escort her back to base camp where Kate
meets major Roy Finch the commanding
officer and soon to be victim of the
monsters she recounts the harrowing
incident to the major but the latter
doesn't believe her story regardless he
takes the hard drive from her shortly
after sergeant Tom hook walks in and
vouches for Kate but the major still
doesn't listen sorry Soldier but if I
believed you it wouldn't be convenient
for the story in the midst of this the
Battalion also finds Kabir and brings
him to the camp for interrogation
afterwards a Medica named KIPP helps
Kate tend to tour injuries during this
she tells Kabir to speak up as he too
witnessed the Monstrous entity but the
latter remains silent moments later Tom
enters the tent and questions Kate about
what she saw in the bunker she recalls
the sign on the bunker door and uses her
photographic memory to transcribe it
that is convenient nobody seems to
understand except for Kabir who
translates the text to do not open he
goes on to explain that the Soviets were
the masterminds behind the situation
when Tom hears this he believes that the
bunker must be approximately 30 years
old and no human can survive inside for
such an extended period without supplies
in response Kabir asserts that whatever
is down there isn't human at night more
creatures break out from their pods and
eventually make their way out of the
bunker meanwhile at the military base
camp the major receives a letter from
his Superior indicating his voluntary
discharge as a result he decides to use
the hard drive that Kate found is
leverage against the superior on the
other hand Kate and KIPP interrogate
Kabir who explains that he didn't shoot
their aircraft and that he is merely a
driver working for the insurgents to
protect his family outside the soldiers
are keeping watch for any insurgents
suddenly a soldier disappears and
another one notices a monster prompting
him to alert everyone the entire unit
swiftly gets into position and opens
fire however the monsters are too fast
and are able to dodge the bullets Tom
conveys the dire situation to the major
who then attempts to call for backup but
unfortunately their radio tower is
destroyed by the Relentless monsters
rendering communication impossible the
situation starts getting intense as
soldiers begin to fall victim to fast
moving adversaries Kip heads out to
assist the wounded soldiers asking Kate
to keep an eye on kubir shortly after a
monstrous creature infiltrates the
medical tent and strangles Kate with its
long tongue it's like Venom but hotter
fortunately Kabir manages to retrieve a
knife from its chest and cuts off the
creature's tongue before stabbing it to
death they're faster than bullets but
not kabir's knife following this the two
rejoined Tom and the other survivors
then Tom and Kip decide to rescue the
major who is locked in a life or death
battle with one of the creatures they
reach him just in the nick of time and
shoot the creature preventing it from
claiming his life upon realizing the
overwhelming numbers of these Monsters
the team opts to seek Refuge within an
empty cargo container while a soldier
named Dave works to unlock the container
another creature launches an attack but
this time Kate reacts swiftly leaping
Atop The Creature and using an ax to
deliver multiple lethal blows to attack
with Tom providing the finishing strike
after this the survivors entered the
container and decide to wait there until
morning while inside the container the
soldiers ask Kabir if he knows anything
about the monsters in response he shares
that the Russians invaded their nation
in the past after a star-like object
landed on the Afghani desert in the
later days the villagers began
disappearing during the night and their
lifeless bodies were discovered by
mourning believing that it's some kind
of wild animal kabir's father decided to
hunt it down but as soon as the Soviets
withdrew the attacks also stopped
unfortunately by that time the village
had already lost 46 people including
kabir's father the next morning the
group cautiously walks out from the
container only to learn that the
monsters have taken away the corpses of
their fallen comrades following this the
soldiers search around the area and
stumble upon a monster's corpse they
take it to the medical tent where kiep
proceeds to conduct an examination his
findings reveal that the creature
possesses shark-like teeth and thick
skin that functions as body armor after
thorough inspection KIPP concludes that
the creatures can't stand sunlight due
to their bodies lacking adaptation to UV
rays in addition he rips through the
monster's body and is shocked to learn
that it has human organs everyone is
confused to hear this but that's when
the major says that these creatures are
hybrids mixed with humans he apologizes
to Kate and reveals that the higher-ups
have always known about the bunker
according to the major it All Began in
1979 when some Soviets came across an
alien spaceship in Afghanistan which
kibera addressed as a star the Soviets
invaded Afghanistan because they needed
the alien DNA to integrate into human
test subjects now that the group doesn't
have enough fuel they must find another
way to escape their conversation is
abruptly interrupted as the creature
reawakens and launches an assault it
grabs Kate with its tongue it likes Kate
with its tongue while also fighting the
other soldiers who try to help her in a
desperate attempt to take down the
creature major Roy sacrifices himself by
grabbing a couple of grenades and
charging the monster in the aftermath
Kate reveals that when the creature
touched her it felt as if it was
draining her thoughts possibly
attempting to read her mind she then
suggests that they blow up the entire
bunker the soldiers agree to do it and
they also decide to freak a beer from
custody regardless Kabir requests to
join them expressing his wish to avenge
his father's death following this the
seven survivors Kate Tom Kip Dave Kabir
Jade and Jones make a bold decision to
blow up the bunker with whatever
ammunition they have left upon reaching
the site they Venture inside and plant
several time bombs but as they are about
to leave Kate drops her locket so Tom
pauses to give it back to her just then
a monster appears from behind and pulls
Tom down into the base believing that
they have lost him the rest of the team
prepares for detonation however moments
before triggering the remote Tom
contacts Kate and instructs the team to
continue with their plan he strictly
tells them not to come looking for him
but Kate doesn't agree with this and
decides to head inside to save him the
other team members initially resistant
ultimately agree upon Kate's insistence
acknowledging that Tom would do the same
for any of them after this the group
gets on a broken elevator and cap lowers
it by using a rope from their vehicle a
short while later kep's radio catches a
frequency alert that warns everyone to
evacuate the area within the next 20
minutes because there will be a missile
strike he immediately relays the
information to the rest of the team but
they decide to carry on with the limited
time the group splits up to cover more
ground quickly and also to just about
guarantee that they won't all make it
out in the meantime Tom finds a monster
in front of him and it soon grabs him by
its tongue Act think swiftly he bites
its tongue ill and retrieves his knife
to stab it to death just then he notices
a dead body of one of his Fallen
Soldiers so he arms himself with the
Soldier's gun and makes his way out as
the team arrives at the lab Kabir
recognizes the decaying bodies on the
tables as the missing people from his
village while looking around Kate finds
a pot on the wall that she didn't see
before she turns on the light only to
discover a huge alien-like creature
floating inside still alive shortly
after Tom contacts Kate to know about
their exact location and finally
reunites with the team inside the team
notices more creatures hatching from
their pots prompting the soldiers to
make a hasty retreat they seal off the
hallway door but someone must stay
behind to keep the door shut in an act
of selflessness Jones volunteers for
this Duty allowing the rest of the team
to escape as they Sprint down the
corridor Jade detects the presence of
the approaching monsters and as a result
she also allows to stay behind to
confront them upon reaching the elevator
the team realizes the Jade is missing
thus Tom makes the decision to go back
for her instructing his team to proceed
without him if he fails to return within
a two-minute window on the other hand
Jade fights a monster and eventually
manages to overpower it however she is
soon confronted by another one by the
time Tom arrives on the scene it's
already too late Jade has fallen victim
to the monster's Onslaught Tom then
grabs a tool in front of him and fights
the creature with it meanwhile in the
hallway Jones can no longer maintain his
grip on the door so he lets it Go and
detonates a bomb taking several monsters
with it Tom hears the explosion and
immediately hides inside of compartments
right before the Flames enter the room
killing the creature but not Tom the
team members who are waiting at the
elevator are also attacked by the
monsters due to this they instruct Kip
to pull them up however Kip appears to
be fighting the insurgents who are now
getting inside the a vehicle somehow
manages to take down one of the
insurgents and activates the elevator to
ascend but unfortunately the elevator
becomes stuck causing the vehicle to be
hoisted instead Kip attempts to stop the
vehicle while also dodging the enemy's
bullets down in the basement the team
members fight desperately for their
lives but tragically Dave succumbs to
the onslaught kep is unable to stop the
vehicle which leaves him with no choice
but to move out of the way and surrender
himself to the insurgents sayonara cute
the truck plunges into the basement
resulting in the demise of everyone
except for Kate who manages to jump away
just in time shortly after Kate reunites
with Tom and the two grab the elevator
wire to make their way up upon exiting
the bunker they spot the insurgents on
the verge of executing in the nick of
time they open fire and eliminate them
rescuing their teammate Long Live
seconds later they witness a fighter
plane dropping a missile in the vicinity
as a result the trio steals the
insurgent's vehicle and flees a massive
explosion occurs but it doesn't reach
the soldiers although it does push the
vehicle off the road Kate believes that
the bombing came from the government to
get rid of the evidence regarding the
existence of the bunker nevertheless she
isn't worried because the major had
handed over the hard drive to her before
his death
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching